it's now hours until the world marks the
moment when Russian President Vladimir
Putin announced he was launching a
special military operation in Ukraine
soon after that speech in the early
hours of the morning 12 months ago the
land sea and air Invasion began since
then the war has killed thousands
displaced millions and destroyed entire
cities today Boris Johnson who led the
international effort to support Ukraine
told Sky News that British security was
at risk if Kiev loses speaking
exclusively he said the UK should break
the ice and provide typhoon fighter jets
soon he also described Vladimir Putin as
a gangster and an adventurer and he
warned Beijing not to support Moscow
the astonishing thing about where we are
today is nobody thought that the
ukrainians were going to hold out for a
week if you remember let alone a year or
very few people thought they would
resist in the heroic way that they have
and it's absolutely crucial that we give
them the supplies the support they need
to get on and finish it this 2023 has
got to be the year of victory for
Ukraine that's the best thing for
Ukraine by the way it's the best thing
for the the Russian people it's the best
thing for the world it's the Humane
thing and let's get on with it
if they don't get those resources and
that equipment and you've talked about
everything they need fighter jets and so
forth if they don't get all that what
could happen in your view
I think that the we we've perpetually
underestimated the ukrainians and
overestimated what Putin can do but
there is clearly a possibility unless
the ukrainians get the help that they
need that Putin can kind of manufacture
out of the land that he's able to retain
some sort of Victory from This Disaster
and he'll be able to to hunker back down
and keep in the the land that he's uh
that he's Acquired and then by this time
and wait till he can attack again that's
why it's so vital that we help the
ukrainians to expunge Putin's forces
from every part of their territory and
not just from the territory that he's
occupied since February the 24th last
year but I think increasingly he's gonna
that he's gonna have to get out of the
whole of 1991 Ukraine they can do it do
not underestimate what the ukrainians
can do they they kicked him out of the
Kiev area where you are now they kicked
him out of the cocky area they kicked
him out of Hassan if they have the right
kit so if they have the Deep fires the
long range artillery if they have enough
tanks we need to give them more tanks
and yes if they have planes to take out
those those Russian Artillery positions
their Russian Commander control as well
then I've got no doubt that President
zolenski's armed forces can recapture
their territory they're fighting for
their country and they're determined to
win
right what are the consequences though
of failure in your view
I think the consequences of any kind of
Putin Victory any kind of uh there was
there's a couple of things first of all
he's able to continue to uh threaten not
just Ukraine but Georgia Moldova the
Baltic states Poland anywhere on the
vast periphery of the former Soviet
Empire don't forget this is what this is
all about he was never really threatened
by Ukraine as a potential NATO member
there was no question of establishing uh
NATO missiles on ukrainians or any of
that nonsense this has purely been done
by Putin to bolster his flagging
position at home and to try to
reconstitute uh the old Soviet Empire so
here in tiri will retain that ability
plus I think it will be a terrible
signal if he has any kind of success it
will be a terrible signal for the world
for everywhere where we care deeply
about borders that should not be changed
by force and clearly the the read across
in the uh in in Southeast Asia uh in uh
in in the South China Seas that's very
clear now uh some top U.S generals are
saying they're reviewing their own
stockpile of weapons because they're
getting so low
Sky's own reporting today suggests that
the UK weapons and ammunition stores are
getting low so low that it risks not
being able to support Ukraine and keep
Britain safe my question is should the
UK put its defense industry on a war
footing I think it's very important that
we continue to make the Munitions that
we need for our our own country and for
the ukrainians as well and uh the the
stuff that we've been able to equip them
with from uh from Belfast from Tyler's
in Belfast that's been absolutely
crucial uh what we've you know we have
stocks we have the when it comes for
instance to uh the tanks and and the
planes we have them the question are
they battle-worthy are they are they
ready uh can people be trained up to use
them I think that in many cases yes and
I just make a crucial point about our
own basically quite clear we don't have
we don't have the stores and the stocks
if uh you know you listen to this what
sky is reporting today people are very
worried about that should we be putting
uh the UK defense industry on a war
footing I I as I said I certainly think
we need to be making sure that we equip
ourselves with what we need but if you
look at the the UK's own defenses and
how to make sure that our own country is
protected and the entire Euro Atlantic
uh security area is protected then the
best thing you can do the most
economical thing you can do is to make
sure that Putin fails in Ukraine and
that the ukrainians win and that is an
investment that we can make in our
long-term security that I think will be
very very financially effective and
economical
yeah but that requires a very big
investment Vladimir Putin is clearly
reorganizing his economy reorganizing
his defense industry and preparing for a
very long War as I say you know should
the UK and other NATO countries be on a
war footing because who knows where this
war is going to lead I don't know what
you exactly mean by a war footing Mark
what I'm saying is that we should
continue to supply the Munitions that we
can we need to make uh more Munitions
and we should recognize when you talk
about the expense
making sure that we are able to save
money save defense expenditure in the
long term because as we just discussed
the risk of any kind of success
by Vladimir Putin is that our general
security would be much more Gravely
imperiled that's why it's essential to
do what we're doing now at the very
least then then does the UK need to
significantly increase defense spending
beyond what you had planned when you
were in office
well if you look at the defense budget
since uh since I came in in 2019
actually the it went up already from I
think slightly under two percent to
about 2.4 percent and just organically
as a result of the the commitments that
the UK is making under uh the future
combat aircraft system or yes yes
we're going up to about three percent
spending more on defense
doesn't significantly increase defense
spending in the next budget would he be
failing as a wartime leader well this is
there's a there's a there's a couple of
sort of ifs there uh Mark and I I think
that uh I I pay tribute to the
government's prime minister defense
secretary what they're continuing to to
do and the UK remains way out uh in in
front it's one of the the big donors uh
to Ukraine not just of of humanitarian
assistance but of that crucial military
assistance and what I'm saying now is
when it comes to things like fighter
jets of course what the what the
ukrainians want is uh f-16s uh
as it happens uh we don't have s60s we
do have typhoons I think there's an
argument for the UK breaking the ice and
and giving them some typhoons if it's a
question of of uh training people up to
use those machines then we can do that
right um just a couple more what would
the consequences be do you think if
China
actively supported Russia in this war by
supplying Weaponry I think it would be a
historic Mistake by the by the Chinese I
was very concerned to see what Wong Yi
was was doing yesterday uh in in Moscow
I I think you know it would be a big
mistake why does China want to be
contaminated by association with with
Putin who's revealed himself to be this
gangster and and adventurer I think it
would be a big mistake by by China but
what it what it shows is the the urgency
of us giving the ukrainians what they
need to succeed this year and to make
sure all that 2023 is the year of
Victory and what about Putin is the
desired outcome regime change in Moscow
no I think it's very important Mark that
we we don't we we've got to stop talking
about Putin he loves us talking about uh
himself and about what's going to happen
in the Kremlin and about his uh nuclear
weapons and all that we should focus on
our Ukrainian friends and on what we can
do to help them to defeat this appalling
invasion of their territory and so far
they have overcome the odds uh time and
again they've proved that they can do it
and they will do it this is basically a
war for independence now Martin Lawrence
for Independence only end one way and
with the US the UK all our friends uh
now are very very strongly in support of
of Ukraine I think they can and they
will win but what I'm saying is let's
not delay if we're going to give them
the kit they need sooner or later if
that's the choice sooner or later let's
give it sooner
um quick one on the Northern Ireland
protocol you've always said that you
would always support your successor will
you support any deal that he does on
brexit in Northern Ireland yeah look I
think that um
it's important that we wait to see what
what there may be but I think the the
best way forward as I've as I I said
when I was uh running the government is
is the Northern Ireland bill which you
know cleared the commons uh very
comfortably I think unamended
um when I was uh when I was in office
and and only a few months ago so I think
that's the the best way forward so you
can't guarantee to back any deal that he
comes up with well you know I think the
best thing is to continue with the uh
the Northern Ireland bill that uh that
we that we agreed and that's a it's a
very good bill it fixes all the the
problems it it solves the uh the
problems that we have in the in the uh
uh no no I know that the RFC it solves
the problems uh of paperwork uh vat and
so on it's a it's a it's an excellent
Bill and doesn't set up any other
problems uh in the economy of the of uh
of the whole island of Ireland so it's
I'd go with that one but it
well it hasn't turned out to be an
excellent bill for many people has it
well it has it went unamended through
the commons I mean it's it's that
okay
um look just one I should put to you to
be fair Kia stama says you and he
loathed each other he dislikes you
because you had no principles what what
do you say to that well actually I I
think that it's very important that
politicians uh get on with each other as
far as they possibly can I had a
perfectly good relationship with him and
um I think that you know
um
it's important to be as civil and as
friendly as you as you possibly can okay
and lastly on Ukraine the Ukrainian
prime minister
said today to Sky News that if Ukraine
loses the war if Putin wins it could
well lead to a third world war uh do you
agree
well I think the stakes are very high I
think that in the sense as we discussed
earlier I just think there's a there is
a real risk that if Putin can
manufacture any kind of success out of
this then
um
he will be able to continue to threaten
not just Ukraine the rest of Ukraine but
all the parts of the former Soviet
Empire that he wants to intimidate and
everybody else around the world will
draw the conclusion Mark that that
aggression pays off and that borders can
be changed by force this is an
absolutely critical moment for the world
this is a this is a pivot moment this is
a hinge of Faith this is the decisive
moment in the early 21st century if
Ukraine wins and I think Ukraine will
win and I know Ukraine can win with our
help then that will be absolutely
critical for our security for decades to
come if on the other hand as you say
Putin is able to manufacture some kind
of Victory I think that will be a a blow
for peace stability and for prosperity